struggle for feminism is part of a
broader struggle for equality within
society
and so my
utopian
feminist society looks like an
egalitarian society
it's the cost of plowing your way up the
hierarchy is so enormous that by the
time you get there
you're either exhausted cynical or male
but it turns out that there is no such
thing as a universal woman there is no
such thing as woman unmodified and the
problem is that some so many laws um so
many um of our campaigns tend to assume
that there is such a thing
[Music]
thank you very much and good morning
wonderful to see you
good audience ready to wake up to uh to
discussion of feminism it's um 50 years
and i regret to say i do remember it
since the second wave of feminism uh got
going and and
time to reflect on where we are so we've
got progress in some areas we've got
more women in parliament we've got more
women in the boardroom and a handful of
ceos so
even the bbc is lumbering towards better
gender balance in its representation
but what has budget at the same time is
the gap between elites and uh the rest
of us uh so
you've got a gap equally between
successful women and less successful
women so the question we're going to
look at this morning is whether that gap
whether the success that feminism has
had in penetrating the elites
is perhaps bad for sisterhood is there
solidarity is the success of of an elite
uh group of women good for all women or
not um are female care workers and ceos
really still on the same side
and to um to discuss this we have um an
eminent uh panel beginning on my far
left with kimberly crenshaw who's a
distinguished professor of law at ucla
her books include mapping the margins
she's she's an expert on race and gender
an expert on many things actually
to my immediate left margaret hefferman
uh entrepreneur one of those successful
ceos uh turned author her book willful
blindness was the
financial times business book of the
decade which is
pretty uh pretty impressive um and to my
right miriam francois who's a political
commentator theorist and uh broadcaster
focuses on on islam and feminism and the
middle east so um i'm looking forward to
hearing what they have to say on the
subject and i'm going to ask them to
begin
um uh miriam perhaps uh you could uh
begin to and
tell us uh to address the the theme of
the day the debate in four minutes
sisters and sisterhood in four minutes
are the female elite threatening the
sisterhoods um
i would probably want to start out by
unpicking a lot of the terms in that so
um who who gets to define who this elite
are how are we defining success
um
are we taken over now within discourses
on feminism by
um ideas that are being defined by a
global capitalist system according to
which essentially the measure of
someone's worth is their productive
capability within this broader system
and the extent to which that comes to
define our priorities within feminism
so the elite are these quote unquote
successful women running big companies
and earning lots of money
but essentially you could flip it in
another way and say that uh
they're part of a very small elite that
uh requires the exploitation of a large
number of people male and female uh in
order to accrue an increasingly
significant amount of wealth
towards an increasingly small number of
people and so i'm not sure that they'd
be my elite or my notion of what would
be success
and then when it comes to the notion of
sisterhood
i find the term a little bit fluffy
personally
i prefer the term solidarity which i
think has much more
implications for notions of mutuality
accountability
and recognitions of common interests i
would even want to unpick the notion
that women as a category
are
necessarily bound by shared experiences
i think even within the same societies
women
experience
very different versions
of
quote unquote equality or inequality
prejudice
and so
it's therefore difficult to talk about
shared struggles
uh in any meaningful sense without
looking at the broader
power relations within which individual
women find themselves
and so more funny to just maybe end on
this note i'm not personally that
interested i'm not saying it's an
irrelevant discussion i think it's
important to talk about the struggles of
like the one percent of the one percent
but i'm probably much more interested in
the extent to which the one percent of
the one percent are contributing to
deepening
worsening economic precarity for a large
number of people male and female and
amongst that group of men and women
who have very different experiences it
should be said and that the developing
world or the global south is very
differentiated it shouldn't be presented
as one group
but within that women tend to suffer the
hard wedge of it
well i guess you know
in theory
i'm part of this elite right because i'm
a woman i've been a ceo
i have in conventional corporate terms
been very successful
i'm extremely
unhappy
about that
i mean i was reflecting before we came
in this morning
of
an experience i had when i was a senior
executive producer at the bbc and my
boss
put his arm around my shoulder because
you could do that in those days
and said good old margaret she's one of
the chaps
and he meant it as a compliment and i
think at the time
i probably took it as a compliment
and i can also remember when i was
working in the united states i was
running vc backed software companies
um my lead investor
thinking i'd been off on vacation
because he'd completely failed to notice
i was pregnant
so i was clearly doing a fantastic job
of being a guy
and and i'd have to say this doesn't
fill me with pride it fills me with
horror
because i think the truth is that as
marvelous as it is to see women at the
top of organizations
the cost is very high
i think the cost is fundamentally not
always and with differing degrees but
nevertheless the cost is one
of assimilation
and you know to be absolutely honest i
didn't come into business to maintain
the status quo
and i didn't want to get the power to
run organizations
to perpetuate the status quo i always
thought the whole point
of being a marginalized outside group
was to come in and shake things up
and i still think that
i still think the way most of our
organizations run are run
is inept unkind unfair
cruel wasteful and unproductive
and i think that those of us who are on
the outside probably see that more
clearly than those who are in on the
inside
i also think
trickle down doesn't work in any context
it doesn't work economically
it doesn't work in sport having a couple
of olympic athletes has not increased
sports participation or the health of
the nation
and trickle-down doesn't work
when it comes to
women to ethnic minorities to any
marginalized group having a couple of
figureheads at the top it's great having
the role models and saying it can be
done
but it doesn't move
it doesn't redefine the norm in any
meaningful way
and i think we also experienced that
under mrs thatcher who was you know a
role model of female leadership that was
highly assimilated to male norms and did
absolutely nothing for women i think
this target of 30 percent of board
members being female will do nothing to
change the way our corporations
are run or managed i think we need a
much deeper
more grass roots
movement if we're going to effect any
change and i'm absolutely mortified and
disheartened by the fact that billions
of pounds
have been spent over the last 20 to 30
years on diversity campaigns in schools
in corporations in the nhs in
institutions
and we've seen virtually no change at
all so i don't think focusing on the top
is going to get us to where we need to
go
you